os sonhos são um instrumento pelo qual
aquilo que está dentro de nós de forma
latente a nossa força consiga se
concretizar consiga se exterioriza
embora não pareça todos nós já
realizamos muitos sonhos na nossa vida é
só voltar um pouquinho da nossa história
e perceber a nossa trajetória
porém alguns dos sonhos que nós temos
muitas vezes ficam apenas na nossa mente
apenas no papel e não conseguem ser
colocados em prática
seja por um motivo ou outro muitas vezes
e iniciar um relacionamento iniciar uma
nova amizade mudar de emprego iniciar um
empreendimento buscar a criação de um
produto novo inúmeros são os sonhos que
nós temos na nossa vida mas
aparentemente parece que existe uma
força que faz com que nós consigamos ou
não atingir cada um deles
muitas pessoas acreditam que o sonho só
se realizam quando nós temos fatores
técnicos para nos auxiliar recursos
financeiros ferramentas
porém por mais recursos financeiros que
tenhamos por mais técnicas e por mais
ferramentas por trás de tudo isso sempre
há um indivíduo sempre ao protagonista
que sou eu que é você que a cada um que
é dono da sua história é protagonista da
sua história e sem esta pessoa não
adianta ter técnica ter ferramentas e
ter recursos é sobre isso que nós vamos
conversar um pouco durante a tarde de
hoje
alguns motivos nos fazem desistir dos
nossos sonhos outros fazem não conseguir
colocar os nossos sonhos em prática e
nós ficamos adiando e procrastinando a
decisão de colocar as nossas metas em
ação
eu selecionei aqui três motivos que não
são os únicos mas pela minha leitura são
os motivos que atualmente leva muitas
pessoas a não conseguir realizar os seus
objetivos
o primeiro deles é exatamente a
procrastinação é um termo da moda
muitas pessoas têm falado sobre isso mas
o que é a procrastinação
depois eu faço depois eu vejo depois do
estudo
depois eu corro atrás depois depois
depois sobretudo em um mundo cada vez
mais conectado cada vez mais globalizado
quando nós estamos com todas as
informações na palma da nossa mão
muitas vezes é difícil manter o foco
naquilo que é necessário é difícil
manter o foco no estudo é difícil manter
o foco nos objetivos
nós desejamos concretizar quem de nós já
passou pela experiência de ficar
querendo saber a que horas são e aí você
pega seu celular
e ao invés de só olhar as horas você
desbloqueia e não tem nenhuma mensagem
pra você não antes
mas você vai lá olhar o status de todos
os amigos e aí você resolve abrir o
youtube ou o instagram o facebook ou
twitter e de repente você perdeu o meia
hora mexendo no celular você bloqueia
ele novamente
você pode se perguntar que horas são
nossa eu peguei o celular para fazer
isso e essa melhora se passou
simplesmente você não percebeu isso é
procrastinação é muitas vezes não
colocar o foco no momento em que nós
precisamos na atividade que nós estamos
realizando o segundo que o elenco é o
medo
todos somos repletos de medo medo de
inúmeros fatores medo de errar medo de
fracassar medo do que as pessoas vão
falar daquilo que nós estamos fazendo
medo de não conseguir o medo pessoal é
algo inerente à natureza humana
todas as pessoas sentem medo em
situações que são desafiados em
situações que são diferentes daquilo que
eles elas estão acostumadas e muitas
vezes as pessoas erroneamente pensam que
os grandes líderes que os grandes
vencedores não tem medo
nossa pessoa destemida chegou até lá mas
aquela pessoa também teve medo porque
todos nós temos medo
o que nós não podemos fazer é deixar o
medo seu protagonista na nossa vida
devemos sim colocar o medo no lugar e aí
quando nós decidimos tomamos a decisão o
medo faz parte da nossa caminhada
mas ele não dita mais aquilo que nós
vamos fazer nós próprios decidimos que o
medo continua existindo conosco então a
coragem não é a ausência de medo mas a
coragem assim avançar mesmo que o medo
esteja presente e o terceiro item que o
elenco aqui é a falta de autoconfiança
muitas vezes não nos sentimos capazes
não nos sentimos merecedores do sucesso
das vitórias do êxito
o ex tenista gustavo kuerten o guga
conta na sua autobiografia que depois
que atingiu o número 1 do mundo depois
de vencer pizza amplas e andré agassi no
mesmo torneio coisa que ninguém mais
conseguiu
ele levantava todas as manhãs e ficava
me perguntando se ele realmente era o
melhor tenista do mundo e ele comenta
que nós brasileiros muitas vezes temos
esse alto desprezo
não acreditamos no nosso potencial
muitas vezes outras culturas estão mais
acostumados a se enxergarem como
vencedores
desde pequena idade então a falta de
autoconfiança muitas vezes é aquilo que
também nos impede de avançar rumo aos
nossos objetivos aqui estão três tipos
de dificuldades que surgem na nossa vida
durante a nossa caminhada é importante
também refletirmos a respeito da
finalidade das dificuldades
muitas vezes queremos fugir das
dificuldades mas as dificuldades são
algo benéfico na nossa vida é por meio
das dificuldades que nós conseguimos
crescer
degrau a degrau na nossa escalada de
evolução na nossa escalada de
exteriorização da nossa capacidade
eu tenho um filho de três meses está
sentado ali é bonitinho e cada dia é uma
descoberta nova e ele faz uma descoberta
nova que nós fazemos em relação a ele
ele tem muitas dificuldades na vida que
são inerentes à idade dele
ele ainda não consegue falar ele ainda
não consegue nem gatinhar ele não
consegue andar mas a cada vitória que
ele alcança na vida dele
a cada momento em que ele consegue fazer
algo diferente ele abriu um sorriso
muito grande e nós vibramos de alegria
junto com ele porque porque no momento
em que nós conversamos com ele ele tenta
bobo se algumas vogais e consegue
perceber que nós estamos entendendo
aquilo que ele está dizendo ele fica
feliz porque está vencendo as
dificuldades inerentes à idade dele e eu
errei muito a minha infância o quanto eu
queria sempre um desafio subir em uma
árvore mais alta jogar algum esporte que
talvez não soubesse ainda todos nós de
certa forma somos assim
somos movidos a desafios só que em algum
momento da nossa história
muitas vezes perdemos a noção de que a
dificuldade é algo que vem nos ajudar e
começamos a achar que a dificuldade é um
obstáculo que não consegue ser
transposto então essa visão a respeito
da dificuldade é fundamental não no
sentido de buscarmos dificuldades
voluntariamente desde que elas venham ao
natural
mas quando surge alguma dificuldade que
nós temos a certeza de que aquilo que
apareceu pra nós
apareceu porque nós temos condições e
capacidade de superá las e por meio da
superação das dificuldades nós vamos
aprendendo a viver cada vez melhor a
nossa vida
eu saí de casa muito cedo quando
terminei oitava
série no ano de 1999 meu pai me chamou
pra conversar
ele disse assim luciano eu quero te dar
uma com uma educação de qualidade
mas a nossa família não tem condições
financeiras de investir em uma escola
particular
então eu tenho duas opções para você a
partir do ano que vem
a primeira delas é você estudar em um
seminário para se tornar padre
no país nunca tinha falado aquilo pra
mim porque pensamos por que será que ele
quer ouvir padre e ele disse você vai
ter um estudo de qualidade e se você
sentir que a sua vocação você pode tomar
essa decisão
depois eu fiquei sabendo do meu bisavô
avô dele
sonhava em ter um neto padre meu pai
meus filhos não quiseram seus primos
deles também não e aí o pai achou que
talvez né o bisneto pudesse atender a
esse sonho e meu bisavô ea segunda opção
que ele me deu ele me falou o seguinte é
luciano existe uma opção que é você sair
de casa e morar com seu irmão que
naquele momento
morava mais ou menos 250 quilômetros da
cidade que meus pais moravam lá no rio
grande do sul fazer um curso técnico
estudar durante o dia com isso você vai
conseguir ganhar o seu dinheiro vai
conseguir um estudo de qualidade e pode
se desenvolver profissionalmente como eu
achei que não tinha vocação pra padre eu
optei pela segunda opção e no ano de
2000 então com 14 anos eu fui morar com
o irmão fazer o curso técnico em
eletrotécnica e comecei a trabalhar no
mercado profissional como estagiário e
logo na seqüência foi efetivado também
de lá pra cá nunca deixei de trabalhar
desde os 14 anos
só que nós não contávamos é que nesse
mesmo ano de 2000 o meu irmão receberia
uma proposta de emprego para sair do rio
grande do sul onde ele estava e vir
morar em curitiba e aí eu fiquei sozinho
uma cidade desconhecida apenas com os
meus amigos da república meus colegas de
trabalho
meus amigos na escola mas sem nenhum
familiar ea partir dali
nessa trajetória do curso técnico em
eletrotécnica eu me apaixonei por expor
pelo curso me apaixonei pelo trabalho
que realizava e decidir me tornar um
engenheiro eletricista
terminado o curso técnico e até iniciei
uma faculdade particular
lá no interior do rio grande do sul mas
com o salário que recebia eu conseguia
pagar somente metade da faculdade
então pra que eu me formar se eu levar
mais de dez anos talvez 12 ou 15 porque
engenharia
nunca se sabe quando você vai se formar
mas não
tinha condições de continuar daquele
jeito então em 2004 eu decidi morar em
curitiba e em função de buscar novas
oportunidades de estudo e trabalho meu
irmão também estava em curitiba e aí me
recebeu e inicie uma trajetória aqui não
tinha condições ainda de fazer
engenharia porque não tinha condições
financeiras de pagar uma faculdade
particular e também não tinha condições
de não trabalhar e fazer uma faculdade
pública então eu cursei o curso superior
de tecnologia em automação industrial
na utfpr universidade tecnológica
federal do paraná
mas o sonho quando está dentro da gente
ele palpita e depois que terminei as
matérias do curso de tecnólogo aquele
sonho continuar optando dentro de mim
querendo que eu fosse engenheiro e no
ano de 2008 então eu decidi me tornar
engenheiro
como eu não sabia mas o primeiro passo
foi a decisão e quando decidi me tornar
engenheiro primeira coisa que eu fiz foi
me matricular no cursinho pré vestibular
do segundo semestre de 2008 eu fiz três
coisas eu estudei e trabalhei e continuo
me dedicando às atividades voluntárias e
uma filosofia chamadas haitiano e com a
filosofia japonesa que eu participo
desde criança eu não interromper essa
atividade voluntária para que
continuassem me dedicando a esses três
aspectos
é naquele momento o segundo semestre de
a universidade federal do paraná abriu
um curso de engenharia eletrônica à
noite que poderia ser a minha salvação
não era o meu objetivo porque eu queria
cursar engenharia eletrotécnica
mas se nada der certo talvez possamos do
vestibular eu poderia fazer esse curso
noturno e me matriculei neste curso me
matriculei também na utfpr no curso de
engenharia industrial elétrica com
ênfase em eletrônica
me dediquei bastante rezei meditei
estudei muito e graças a esse empenho
todo felizmente passei os dois
vestibulares
o pessoal do meu trabalho sabia dessa
luta que estava enfrentando e no momento
em que eles souberam que eu fui aprovado
no vestibular rasparam a cabeça fiquei
linda né sem cabelos e meu chefe
vendo tudo aquilo me chamou para
conversar e me perguntou luciano qual
das duas faculdades você deseja fazer e
eu falei pra ele eu quero fazer
engenharia elétrica na utfpr
só que o curso tem aulas à tarde e à
noite e eu trabalho de manhã e de tarde
então não sei como fazer aí ele me deu
uma das melhores notícias daquele ano
ele disse luciano
como você vai fazer um curso
o relato a área em que você trabalha a
nossa empresa tem uma política interna
que pode flexibilizar os seus horários
de trabalho
você pode cumprir talvez as 40 horas não
no horário convencional mas em horários
diferenciados
teria que cumprir 40 horas mas poderia
flexibilizar então montei meu horário
ele ficou da seguinte forma quatro dias
e quatro dias da semana eu entraria às
seis da manhã
sairia meio-dia almoçaria rapidinho
começaria a aula uma tarde na utfpr
na outra tarde que no dia seguinte no
último dia eu trabalhei até às 15 e aí
depois iria para a aula
com isso eu fazia 32 horas e sobrava 18
para fazer no sábado o chefe ou horário
e falou pra mim você tem certeza que
você quer fazer dessa forma você não
quer deixar algumas matérias para trás e
eu parei psdc deixar algumas matérias
para trás meu horário vai ser pior ainda
depois não quero fazer todas elas
ele fala tudo bem então tá assinou
passou para o superintendente
surpreendido e tirou o papel me chama
para conversar e disse você não tem
noção da dificuldade que é um curso de
engenharia eu falei acho que tenha eu
tenho certeza que você vai fazer isso eu
falei ontem e ele disse você não vai
conseguir é muito puxado trabalhar 40
horas e fazer um curso praticamente
integral
eu falei mas isso era autorizar eu quero
me dar esse desafio e buscar correr
atrás desse sonho e foi então tá
eu vou te autorizar e assim começou a
minha história na engenharia
no ano de 2009 levantava às seis da
manhã trabalhava estudava e fazer todas
essas coisas
durante o curso nesse início
principalmente é para que não
atrapalhasse ainda mais os horários das
minhas aulas no meu trabalho e para que
fizesse valer a pena todo o esforço eu
decidi não reprovar nenhuma matéria da
faculdade de engenharia eo meu super nem
superintendente tinha razão o curso
realmente é difícil cálculo um de 46
alunos apenas 12 passaram na primeira
tentativa e eu era um deles e assim foi
fui me esforçando bastante peguei férias
três ou quatro vezes no final do
semestre para estudar para fazer
trabalhos
o tempo foi passando e eu adiantei
algumas matérias peguei equivalências da
outra faculdade que eu tinha e no
primeiro semestre de 2013 eu me formei
engenheiro eletricista pela universidade
tecnológica federal do paraná
cinco meses antes do tempo normal de do
curso seis meses perdão antes
no tempo normal decurso que há cinco
anos eu fui o único da turma que
conseguiu adiantar formatura e um dos
poucos que trabalhava desde o início do
curso e da minha turma de origem apenas
cinco pessoas conseguiram concluir o
curso em cinco anos e essa experiência
trouxe muita muitos valores para mim
porque várias outras vezes eu fui
desafiado e disse eu consegui fazer
aquilo com certeza conseguir fazer isso
também
hoje o trabalho como engenheiro
eletricista concursado em uma das
maiores empresas do paraná
me sinto muito feliz muito realizado
profissionalmente também tudo isso
porque alguns valores fizeram parte de
toda essa caminhada e esses valores que
eu quero compartilhar com vocês
o primeiro deles a importância da
decisão senão tivesse decidido cursar
mesmo sem saber como em 2008 se não
tivesse entrado no cursinho
provavelmente hoje não seria engenheiro
ainda se esperar essas condições
externas favorecerem a minha vida
provavelmente eu ainda não seria um
engenheiro talvez não fosse nenhum
universitário quando nós tomamos a
decisão as coisas começam a acontecer
as pessoas gostam de colaborar as
pessoas colaboradores surgem para nos
ajudar a concretizar os nossos objetivos
então a decisão é fundamental por mais
que nós não saibamos ainda como fazer se
nós temos algo dentro de nós dizendo
faça isso tome a decisão e faça o que
com certeza as coisas vão acontecer
o segundo ponto é a disciplina a
disciplina é fundamental
eu lembro que durante os quatro anos e
meio de curso eu participei de dois
churrascos o churrasco dos calouros e
churrasco da formatura
a disciplina isso a disciplina você
manter o foco naquilo que é necessário e
muitas vezes abrir mão do resto abrir
mão de coisas que não são tão
necessárias para que você possa alcançar
os seus objetivos
então é um ponto muito importante para
que nós consigamos o êxito na vida e por
fim a resiliência à residência também um
termo da moda ela tem muitas pessoas
falam mas ele é realmente muito
importante porque a residência faz com
que você tire as lições das dificuldades
que você aprenda aquilo que as
dificuldades vêm trazer para sua vida e
incorpore isso ao seu caráter
no momento em que uma próxima
dificuldade surgir você está mais
confiante para enfrentar aquela
dificuldade e conseguirá avançar cada
vez mais rumo ao sucesso esses três
valores que eu coloquei aqui decisão
disciplinar residência nos ajudam a
combater aquelas limitadas
eu coloquei antes a decisão nos ajuda a
enfrentar o medo
quem já andou numa montanha russa sabe
disso porque no momento que você entrou
no carrinho e trancar o carrinho meu
amigo pode ter medo quanto for mas você
vai ter que é assim que funciona quando
nós tomamos a decisão com medo ou sem
medo vai
e aí nós começamos a superar o medo na
nossa vida a disciplina nos ajuda a
eliminar ou reduzir muito a
procrastinação e com isso nós
conseguimos alcançar os nossos objetivos
e por fim a resiliência fortalece muito
a nossa autoconfiança porque na medida
que nós vamos enfrentando e superando os
nossos desafios nós vamos cada vez mais
rapidamente alcançando o êxito por maus
sonhos nós buscamos para a nossa vida
então para encerrar gostaria de dizer
que a decisão de fazer acontecer
está dentro de cada um de nós se a
situação externa não está propício ainda
crie você uma própria situação que você
consiga resolver aquilo que precisa ser
resolvido não espere de fora
quando nós assumimos a responsabilidade
pela nossa vida nós deixamos de esperar
que as coisas aconteçam para então ser
os protagonistas
nós nos tornamos protagonistas desde já
desejo que cada um de vocês coloquem
seus sonhos seus ideais as suas metas em
prática e seja cada dia mais feliz
porque com certeza muitas pessoas
realizando seus sonhos a sociedade só
tem a melhorar as pessoas só têm a
crescer e com certeza criaremos uma
sociedade cada vez melhor
agradeço imensamente pela atenção de
todos e até uma próxima oportunidade
muito obrigado